(suspenseful music)
- Ah, look at that.
That is one big poo.
(grunts in disgust)
That to me looks like bear poo.
And that is not entirely good news.
That is why you got to be so
careful in these mountains.
We are not alone out here.
If you got bears in the area,
it means we've got to be doubly careful.
But actually look at this, look.
Oh, God.
Se the actual little bits of nuts?
(grunts in disgust)
Try and get one out,
there you go, see that?
It's actually not digested.
So, the bear's obviously
eating a lot of nuts,
a lot of fruit and not
all of it gets absorbed
and actually, if you're desperate,
that could actually be a food source.
All you need to do
is wash this off.
Get all the bacteria and
the fecal matter off it
and you're then left with,
oh, God.
You're left with a little
nut, a little kernel bit
and if you wash that, you
could actually eat that,
but it does come with its risks.
You don't wanna get sick.
You end up eating bacteria,
like all of that bit,
if you don't wash it well.
And then you're in trouble.
Sometimes you're better off being patient
and waiting, and looking
for another food source.
So, what are we gonna do?
Am I gonna pick all
the little bits of nuts
out of this bear poo, wash
them off and eat them?
Or am I gonna keep hunting,
now we're amongst the trees,
and look for something else?
Maybe some bug scrubs, worms,
you know, maybe squirrel nuts,
anything like that.
So, what are we gonna do?
Let's make a discission.
Are we going for the nuts in the bear poo,
or keep hunting?
How'd I know you were
gonna pick this option?
Picking out the nuts from a bear poo
and washing them off and eating them.
What's wrong with you?
Okay, come on then, let's do this.
Oh, God, it just stinks.
Okay, I'm gonna get some
water from the canteen.
Remember, you only try this
if you're desperate for food.
Okay, I've collected a
few of these little nuts.
I'm gonna wash this off.
The brown stuff is what I wanna get off.
Okay, so look.
So, then you're left with
those little bits like that.
It's really as clean as I can get it
and it's only half digested by the bear.
Another bit there.
Just give me a second
to rinse my mouth out.
(grunts in disgust)
Okay.
Okay, let's keep going.